every day you should be the weakest
person in the room at some point whether
that is in a meeting whether that is in
a
sport whether that is in a gym whether
that is in a chess match it doesn't
matter but i always try to be the
weakest person in the room and i
remember when i was 15
i had my first time
over overseas for any extended period of
time i was in japan for a year and i
ended up
being a judo player i was competing in
judo and
the high school that i went to was not
particularly strong in judo but i was
the big fish in the little pond and i
was i got very high and mighty i thought
i was just
the cat's meow and i wasn't too overt
about it but i was very sort of
satisfied with how well i was doing i
went to my first tournament i got
demolished in seven seconds by this guy
who weighed 40 pounds less than i did
like
you know that was it i was done and i
got up i'm like i'm fine they're like no
you're the loser you're done you are
done and
i was so demoralized
and
uh you know i was the only white guy in
the tournament and it was kind of the
they they said there were a lot of
people just hoping that they would be
able to kind of like wag a finger and
laugh
and i mean love japan but it's like i
get it a very homogeneous place so i
ended up going after that to a cram
school for judo
like ajuku and they have it for all
sorts of things at night and i went to
tokai university's
judo cram school so tokai university
produces gold medalists in the olympics
they're really really tough so i went in
and i was 15 at the time and i got
i got just annihilated by 12 year olds i
mean talking about embarrassing i mean
if you can try to flash back to high
school you're like you know
and you're getting you're like a
sophomore in high school getting killed
by sixth graders or seventh graders
so embarrassing including women i was
getting torn to pieces
and i got trashed for three or four
months and i was like wow
i don't feel like i'm making a lot of
progress my endurance is getting a
little bit better and went to a
tournament that had the same competitors
as the previous tournament and just
walked through everybody just
steamrolled because i had
a better cohort group i was the weakest
in the room right
uh as long as you're trending in the
right direction
it doesn't matter if you're losing
so now help people understand so you've
said that there's a big difference
between repetition and deliberate
practice so how
and
even i like a lot of what i do is
probably a little too close to just
repetition and it's the far too rare
moment where i really stop and think
about weight what piece of this can i
break off
and do until i'm good at that piece and
then reinsert it back into the hole so
i'm not just
repeating it yeah
so how can people conceptualize the
difference between repetition and actual
deliberate practice right because
repetition after an initial point when
you're completely new to something
repetition does not make you better
and this is not it's not obvious right i
mean there's actually this interesting
performance psychology literature
starting the 70s was trying to really
understand
how do people become masters at things
and repetition was one of the
hypotheses maybe you do it a lot turns
out that's not the case
other people thought it was
understanding the world maybe building
up the right mental models that's not
the case it's deliberate practice and so
what's the difference deliberate
practice stretches you
you stretch yourself
past where you're comfortable
with the just like you do with a muscle
right you have to tire out the muscle
exhaust it if you're gonna if you're
gonna get growth right but it's very
uncomfortable stretching is
uncomfortable
and that's why people don't do it but
like when i was trying to upgrade my
writing so my first three books i wrote
as a student and they were student
advice books paperback
and i wanted to be an ideabook hardcover
ideabookwriter i kind of went down to
the wilderness for a while and said i
have to get better at writing and what i
was discovering was like just writing on
my blog for example wasn't stretching me
enough
and so i said i'm going to write for
magazines i found a magazine where you
know they paid for commissions and there
was an editor who was going to accept or
reject it so now i could deliberately
practice i had the stretch to try to get
my my assignments accepted and published
you know by this magazine right it
wasn't just repeating what i was doing
before now i was trying to stretch
myself and i did that for a year
and it made a big difference
and so that's deliberate practice
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you